Pakistani journalist Ahmed Rashid has
spent most of his career reporting on
Central Asian politics in Jihad mr.
Rashid author of the best-selling
Taliban shows that Islamic
fundamentalism is gaining ground in the
region as well as it did in neighboring
Afghanistan he focused specifically on
five former Soviet republics
Turkmenistan Uzbekistan Kyrgyzstan
Kazakhstan and Tajikistan who in a
decade since their independence have
seen a region growing increasingly
despotic and impoverished despite their
oil-rich landscape this program runs
just under an hour Thank You Marshall
thanks so much for that kind
introduction I am pleased and honored to
introduce eMeter XI tonight and to
welcome him to the Kakaako Council on
Foreign Relations mr. Heath's I don't
know if you're aware of what a hard act
you had to follow because it was the
Oscars last night so you know the fact
that there's such a great crowd here is
just testament to the fact that your
work is really important and that
everyone here is really excited to hear
what you have to say what is the stuff
of history and legend to most of us has
been eMeter sheets reality he has
covered Afghanistan Pakistan in Central
Asia for more than 20 years years that
saw the confluence of arms anger and oil
that led to the death of 1.5 million of
Hani's and the total destruction of a
nation while the world turned a blind
eye Ameth receives journalistic I
remained focused we are lucky that it
did and that it still does today from
the coup of 1978 to the fall of gobble
to the Mujahideen after the slaughter of
communist president Najib Allah he was
there dodging bullets by his own words
talking to the leaders and recording
history in the making
before many of us had read about
republics like us Becca Stan
Turkmenistan Tajikistan Kazakh Stein and
Kyrgyzstan on the front pages of our
daily paper
he was there and before we knew what the
word Taliban even meant or who in fact
was sama bin Laden and al-qaeda even
were mr. Rashid knew enough to warn us
all because he was there based in the
city of Lahore Pakistan mr. Rashid is
currently a correspondent for The Wall
Street Journal the Far Eastern Economic
Review and the Daily Telegraph he also
writes for the nation a leading
Pakistani daily newspaper his work has
appeared in foreign affairs the
Washington Post The New York Times and
other important publications he is a
frequent guest on National Public Radio
and appears regularly on US and British
television programs one of the most
sought-after experts on Afghanistan mr.
Rashid recently gave talks and briefings
at the White House the National Security
Council the State Department the
Brookings Institute and to the secretary
of the UN Kofi Annan his book Taliban
militant Islam oil and fundamentalism in
Central Asia became a New York Times
number-one bestseller
Yale University Press has just now
published his new book jihad the rise of
militant Islam in Central Asia which we
are sure here at the council will also
quickly rise to the top of the
bestsellers list a tip to this audience
in case you're not aware mr. Rasheed's
book Taliban told the truth before
anyone really cared before September
11th he wrote that book a long time
before the events happened today we know
that we have reason to care his new book
is about Central Asia and the rise of
militant Islam in that region if that
subjects not important to you today it
no doubt one day will be Emmitt received
is a native of Pakistan and was educated
at Cambridge University in England we
look forward to his remarks because of
his quite obvious expertise in this
important area that we're all here to
learn about today
there will be time for your questions
afterwards but right now please join me
in welcoming a mature seed for the first
time to the platform of the Chicago
Council on Foreign Relations thank you
well what can I say Marshall I've known
for a long time and it's wonderful to
see him here my first trip to Chicago
and a familiar face and hacia thank you
thank you all for coming
I'm extremely grateful I certainly don't
plan to follow on as you know with the
Oscars I don't think I can compete with
that you know let me just start by
saying that I think the in the region as
a whole this is a very very important
moment I think for the United States and
what policies it pursues in Pakistan
Afghanistan and Central Asia I was in
Kabul just five six days ago and I'm
very happy to answer questions at the
end on Afghanistan Central Asia or
Pakistan but I'll try and make a few
comments about you know what I see is
the present situation in three places
first if I can start with Central Asia
this book actually was written well
before it was given into my publishers
in June last year and it was as much
written in the form of a warning to the
West that if you ignore this part of the
world you know there is huge problems
can arise just as much as the Taliban
book was a warning which very few people
paid attention to unfortunately before
September the Americans now have
military bases and three Central Asian
Republics Kazakh O's Becca Stan
Tajikistan and Kyrgyzstan and Central
Asia itself faces militant Islamic
groups who were based in Afghanistan who
were attacking raiding launching
guerrilla attacks into Central Asia
from Afghanistan since 1998 over three
four successive years and but the real
problem in Central Asia has simply been
that the five Republic's who became
independent after the breakup of the
Soviet Union were first very much
ignored by
the West apart from two of them which
have oil and gas resources to Menace tan
and Kazakhstan the American oil
companies Russian Chinese all companies
went in there but politically and
economically speaking there was no real
pressure on these countries as there was
for example on the Baltic republics or
other former Soviet states to reform to
liberalize and what has happened in
Central Asia is simply that you have
five extremely repressive dictatorial
regimes who have carried out very little
economic reform very little political
reform and as a result of that process
without allowing any secular Democratic
opposition to emerge without being able
to reform their economies to provide
jobs for the kind of youth bulge the
population bulge that has emerged in the
last 10 years there in very dire straits
and I feel an immense social and
economic explosion in Central Asia
unless there is very drastic action
taken both by the regimes and by the
Western powers who are now supporting
the regime's and I think it's absolutely
critical the United States has gone in
it has it has acquired military bases
there and the Central Asians have have
obviously loved this because they have
now got kind of the American attention
and American focus for the first time in
10 years but the real game I think is
not going to be about how obliging the
Central Asians are going to be about
providing military bases and access but
about how willing they are going to be
to carry out economic and political
reform and how determined the u.s. is
going to be in trying to push for this
reform unfortunately in the last six
months the United States policies in
Central Asia have really not been linked
sufficiently I think to using
carrot-and-stick
pressure and incentives to get these
leaders to reform the you the US for
example is giving the the largest and
most powerful country in Central Asia
shows beckus tan 160 million dollars of
aid this year which is but that's not
very small by your standards but
I can tell you it's more than ten years
it's more than the total what you know
the Americans have given to us backs
down in ten years
and that's quite apart from the military
aid and I think it's absolutely
essential that that the US and other
Western countries Europeans etc the
World Bank the IMF who are going to be
giving you know increasing aid to the
Central Asian regimes couple that with a
timetable with certain condition a letís
for reform I think it's absolutely
essential because the problem is that if
there is going to be social and economic
unrest the only political alternative to
the regimes at the moment are the
Islamic militant parties it's very much
a situation which is similar perhaps to
what happened in Iran you know in Iran
in 1979 there was a social and economic
rebellion against the Shah it could you
know it could have been led by anyone
but the only people with any kind of
grid and a support inside the population
was Ayatollah Khomeini and and and the
whole religious group and and we know
what happened in Iran we know how
bitterly how you know how strongly the
United States continued to support the
Shah and and of course you know there
have been no relations between Iran and
the United States since 1979 I feel a
very similar situation in Central Asia I
think it's absolutely critical that the
leverage that the US has and please
don't underestimate the leverage I mean
this war in Afghanistan was won by the
Afghans but you know with the the kind
of clout that the US has acquired now in
the region is it's not it's not small
and it should be used wisely it should
be used prudently and it should be used
to do good now the problem here is I see
that you know President Bush and the US
administration is not in favor of what
it calls nation-building but frankly in
Afghanistan the you know Bush may not
like the term and President Vice
President Cheney said you know two days
ago that we are not into nation-building
but actually that's what you're involved
in in Afghanistan you are rebuilding the
army you've just given three hundred
million dollars worth of aid for for the
Rica
destruction of Afghanistan of your
giving aid to two to Central Asia and
the point is that whether you know the
Bush administration likes the word or
not you the terrorism is not going to be
eliminated by purely through military
action it's going to be eliminated by
stabilizing and nation-building in these
states and building institutions which
are long-lasting and and which deliver
goods to the people economic benefit and
and social justice and political reform
to the people which is going to make if
you like Afghanistan a failed state some
of the Central Asian states which I
would describe as failing States giving
them something for the future now in the
same way the present situation in
Afghanistan I think is fraught with a
immense policy dilemmas but essentially
my my sense after spending two weeks in
Kabul is that the the war is now over
what is left is a mopping up operation
against al-qaeda against the remnants of
the Taliban some of whom are regrouping
in Pakistan but the essential military
operation is now over what I think the
US now needs to do more than ever is
clearly during the war did the military
the Defense Department you know we're
running the policy almost exclusively I
think the balance has now shifted what
is needed is other u.s. institutions and
and parts of government to get involved
the State Department needs to now get
involved to evolve a much clearer and
stronger political strategy to support
the the interim government led by Hamid
Karzai to draw in and curb the power of
the Warlord's and to draw them in to
support the interim government the the
USAID the Agency for International
Development needs to get involved
the Treasury Department wants to you
know help the stabilize the Afghan
currency and perhaps establish a new
currency they need to be getting you
know to be getting involved but what we
are seeing on the ground in us in in
Afghanistan is that the Pentagon is
still basically running the policy the
other parts of US government are not
involved
really
the decision-making loop as it were in
Washington and what is now essentially
needed for several reasons one
Afghanistan is now entering a very
critical political process the first
political process for 23 years where the
king is coming back there will be a Loya
Jirga the grand tribal council will meet
in June a composed of up to 800 to a
thousand representatives of the
population and this political process is
going to create hopefully a new central
government a more broad-based central
government by July and it's absolutely
essential that the US has a political
strategy rather than a military strategy
to try and support this political
evolution likewise the reconstruction
and development and reconstruction is
now essential if this political process
is to be supported certainly there's a
lot of humanitarian aid going on and
it's going in and is and is keeping
people from starving but what is not
happening is development and
reconstruction so it's three months
after the international community the
donor community pledged 4.5 billion
dollars at the Tokyo conference for
reconstruction in Afghanistan which
included 300 million dollars for the
u.s. from the US but hey I D has not
been able to set up a single development
project in Afghanistan in the last three
months and the slowness of the
reconstruction process the slowness you
know donor money has not arrived yet in
Kabul the interim government is
literally living hand-to-mouth Hamid cos
day is literally having to go around and
beg some of some friendly countries for
money just to pay salaries to pay you
know immediate expenses of the budget he
went to Saudi Arabia recently and they
gave him ten million dollars and he
bought it back in a suitcase because
there was no other way of you know
because there was no other money coming
into Afghanistan similarly crucial to
reconstruction and development is the
security situation part of you know the
bond agreement which set up the interim
government was that the international
community would support a security force
in Kabul which exists now there are
4,800 foreign troops in Kabul who are
keeping the peace and have very
dramatically stabilized the situation in
the capital but part of the agreement
was also to expand the security force to
other cities in Afghanistan the other
five major cities and the US has
basically vetoed this because the u.s.
feels that you know this will interfere
you know in the war effort now I can
tell you in Afghanistan the even last
week's operation anaconda yes it was a
big operation because for the first time
US troops were on the ground ten US
soldiers were killed 40 50 were wounded
but you know put it in perspective of
Afghanistan Operation anaconda was
carried out in ten square miles of
Afghan territory there was a pocket or a
large pocket well-armed pocket of
al-qaeda but the rest of the country was
not affected by this you know the Afghan
population itself was not affected by
this
there will be more pockets like this and
there will be more resistance like this
but these are in very small geographical
areas of the country and if they should
not be interfering in the political and
security and reconstruction process the
problem now for security is that the
Afghans before the larger gun need
foreign troops in these other cities so
that the political process can be
guaranteed that the Warlord's do not
send their representative and and and
their relatives and aunts and uncles you
know to the Loya Jirga but the people
have a chance to send their
representatives security is needed so
that the NGOs and the UN agencies can go
into these cities to you know start
reconstruction and development which and
also of course help demobilize the
armies of these warlords at the moment
as everyone is calling for the
demobilizing of the above of the armed
you know factions but this can't be done
in a vacuum it's very clearly has to be
linked closely with economic policies
with you know with reconstruction these
young soldiers with these wars have to
be given jobs they have to be given
skills and if you want to send them back
to their farms which many of them want
to go
they have to be given packages of you
know seed fertilizer irrigation and all
the rest of it they cannot just be told
you know well you know I had to put down
your gun and go home go home to what so
the the Afghanistan remains a very
complex equation everything has to
happen at the same time security
political process reconstruction
development you know disarming the
Warlord's but this has to be this you
know the international community and
particularly the United States has to
pursue this out of a political strategy
now rather than a mere military strategy
in which the military determines what
should happen and what should not happen
in other fields so I'm you know very I
remain optimistic I think you know the
Afghans despite all the problems and
despite the very messy situation still
existing I mean I've got it sounded at
23 years of war but let me assure you
that I mean 99 percent of the peak of
the population are fed up I mean they
want peace they want the end of
warlordism
they want reconstruction just look at
this you know in fact the only puzzle
you know the only national event that
has taken place has been the back to
school I don't know if you read about it
1.5 million children went back to school
two days ago including girls and boys a
program that cost fifty million dollars
organised by UNICEF right across the
country and kids were you know it's the
first time this has happened in 23 years
I mean the first time that mothers have
been actually you know said goodbye to
their children and sent them off to
school in 23 years I mean it's a hugely
healing kind of process and it's and
most important it didn't just happen in
Kabul it happened in every corner of
Afghanistan and let me tell you why it
happened it happened because the u.s.
want because the president's wife Laura
Bush one was committed to this and she
helped a I D publish 8 million text
books for this you know now what you
know people I mean friends of
Afghanistan would like to see is the
Americans get involved in more such
processes you know Laura Bush should
have to get involved in every single you
you know unifying strategy taken by the
Americans in Afghanistan but you know
this was a process you need more
programs like this to bring the country
together this very fact of Education
diminishes the kind of legacy of the
Taliban diminishes the Warlord's because
the Warlord's don't provide education
the central government with the help of
the UN and the and the aid agencies
provide education
so everything that chips away at the old
kind of war legacy in Afghanistan is
immensely beneficial right now so you
know at the moment I'm I'm ayah I remain
positive I think you know the bond
agreement essentially that set up this
government was essentially a partnership
it was a partnership between the
international community on one hand and
the Afghan interim government on the
other where I think at the moment the
the biggest failings are possibly you
know by the international community
the lack of the expansion of security in
the other Afghan cities and the the
slowness of this reconstruction process
I think the international community can
rectify this very quickly if it wants to
and certainly if the Americans take the
lead I think you know they were
rectified it's probably even quicker the
third area obviously of enormous
interest is Pakistan Pakistan has been
going through you know a complete roller
coaster ride as many of you will know
since September the 11th let me just
briefly say there was a million there is
a military regime in Pakistan which for
the last six years has backed and
supported the Taliban President
Musharraf did a u-turn on September 13th
14th facing immense international
pressure and I think also personally
from himself from his own self seizing
an opportunity to do perhaps what he has
wanted to do for a long time which was
to curb the kind of extremism that was
going on you know in Pakistan being
generated
in Pakistan is support for the Taliban
the some of the supporting some of the
extremist groups in Kashmir but there
you know I think there and and of course
you know Pakistan again has been hit by
a very serious wave of terrorism in the
last few few weeks with the killing of
Danny Pearl the attack on the the church
in Islamabad but you know let me make a
few comments I think the problem in
Pakistan was that when when the military
may took this decision there was I mean
any thinking Pakistani knew very well
that there were a couple of other things
the military there was a logic to doing
the u-turn on the Taliban you had to
also do a u-turn on extremism inside
Pakistan and a u-turn on this whole kind
of culture that has been generated in
Pakistan over the last 20 years well
I've called in the Taliban book this
kind of madrasa culture the culture of
of religious schools who teach you know
jihad and extremism as being the kind of
only a part of Islam which should be
followed and that was you know the
second logic and the third logic was
that because most of these militant
groups were linked to the the fighting
in Kashmir there had to be some kind of
genuine effort to deal with that and to
deal with with the very tense
relationship with India now
unfortunately the you know I think the
military regime wasted a lot of time
between September and the landmark
speech that Musharraf gave on January
the 12th the military actually did
nothing of stage 2 and stage 3 which of
course set the scene for a reaction from
these militant groups they attacked the
Indian Parliament in January they
attacked the Kashmir legislature and
then they attack targets inside Pakistan
and since of course January 12th
Musharraf has banned five extremist
groups there's been a big crackdown but
I still think there's an enormous amount
that the military needs to do and and
strategically speaking they the military
is now is faced with with with two
problems and how it addresses these
problems are going to really
I think signal you know the future
stability of Pakistan the first very
much is education how it deals with this
mother as our culture in my own opinion
and opinion of most educationalist this
madrasa culture cannot be modernized or
rectified on its own what is needed is
the rebuilding of the state educational
system as it existed in Pakistan 20
years ago it is the state educational
system which you know which is a modern
system which teaches all the subjects
and all the rest of it which can really
carry out literacy campaigns and which
can educate people and reduce the
influence of the madrasa system it is
unfortunate that the muck that the
military right now is seeking funding
from the United States and from the
World Bank and other powers is seeking a
hundred million funding to modernize
what it calls a madrasah system well the
mother of the system cannot be
modernized the modesta system has a
particular role in Muslim societies
which was essentially to turn out
scholars and mullahs to run the mosques
it can turn out engineers and doctors
and you know professionals so the key
issue here is the big debate going on in
Pakistan right now about how you know
that the issue of education has to be
tackled and frankly many educationalists
in Pakistan are up in arms against the
military attitude that somehow
modernizing madrasahs is going to make
them kind of acceptable and and and
modern it's not I mean the other major
issue of course an even more strategic
issue is the issue of elections I think
it's you know Musharraf has to hand
power in October he's promised elections
by October he's now going for a
referendum for himself to make tutu to
validity 8 is that his the presidency
for the next 5 years
now I think there's enormous popular
support for Musharraf I mean you know
this is a military dictator he seized
power in a coup
he's ostracized a lot of politicians but
they what we sheriff has done since
September I think there's a lot of a lot
popular support but the point is that
this popular support is not for
continued military monopoly of power
what I think people hope and expect is a
genuine attempt by the military to share
power with the civilians which means you
have to have a free and fair election
now I don't think people in Pakistan
will mind given the crises that we're in
the Indian Army is mobilized on one side
you know chaos in Afghanistan on the
other side a huge economic recession at
home I don't think people will mind a
sharing of power for a certain period of
time between the military and the
civilian you know politicians and civil
society but civil society has to feel
that the military genuinely wants to
share power unfortunately there have not
been sufficient signals by Musharraf or
by the army that the army is really
serious about sharing power with
civilians and and with civil society as
a whole it's not just a question of
whether Musharraf wants to share power
with benazir bhutto anniversary
these are failed politicians from the
past it's a question of whether the
military is going to show respect for
civil society and whether it's going to
involve civil society in dealing with
all the problems that we face you know
education democracy modernization etc
now again the fear here is that the u.s.
because of the military facilities that
Pakistan has provided to the United
States is going to endorse basically
whatever Musharraf wants well you know
I'm very one I think a lot of people in
parks are very worried by that I think
there has to be also sufficient pressure
on the military that a free and fair
process is needed a genuine election is
needed a genuine signal to civil society
is needed that the military is not going
to spend the next five years
monopolizing power and setting up a
puppet government at the end of an
electoral process you know we're in six
months time there's going to be you know
a political protest in the street
because we've been down that road before
and and some of you who know Pakistan
know very well that in in the last
military period under Gerald Hutt he
tried to do exactly this he went for a
referendum
he went for a rigged election it
produced a rigged Parliament and and and
in fact it produced a puppet prime
minister what he thought was a prophet
Prime Minister who then rebelled against
the al-haq and in fact the aaalac was
then forced to roust him and you know
just before his death and of course that
led to a series of political crises
which means still living with so we have
been down that road before we know the
consequences of a rigged election and
and and a rigged government where you
know genuine where power is not
genuinely solved I think you know this
is a very historic moment for Pakistan I
mean after ten years out in the cold the
decisions taken by the military after
September have been extremely positive
bringing back stand back into the kind
of international arena and all the rest
of it but again they box on is now faced
with very difficult choices the regime
is faced with very difficult choices I
hope it makes the right choices
I hope the United States also makes the
right choices so what I'm really saying
is that I think you know in all these
three areas it's essential that I think
the United States tries now to adopt a
much more nuanced sophisticated
multi-dimensional political strategy to
deal with the problems of central asia
pakistan afghanistan which which need
political and economic and solutions not
purely military solutions the favors
that these countries have done the us by
providing bases and all the rest of it
those favors are now past i mean this
happened the war has been won what is
left now of course is you know the
muffing up in afghanistan and and and of
course what is left also is a mopping up
well much more than the mopping up is
cracking the al-qaeda network in the
rest of the world which frankly has not
been done yet and which requires a very
concerted effort by the US and by the
coalition forces the the networks in the
United States the networks in Europe and
in other Muslim countries I don't you
know I mean that war is certainly not
one in fact that war has not even
started in fact I mean if you look at
the the u.s. effort in six months I
think you've arrested one
al Qaeda known suspect you have not
broken a single cell yet of al Qaeda in
the United States nor do Europeans so
this is a very very serious problem and
it's you know this is a this is a but
but this too is the war of intelligence
and information and you know subtlety
and and and all the rest of it it can't
be done with a sledgehammer it has to be
done with you know with different tools
so I but I hope you know in in you know
the region I live in I hope there is
going to be a much more nuanced strategy
which will bring you know the u.s. in
favor you know with with the peoples of
the region the US has to make friends
with peoples of the region and it has to
then you know to do that it has to deal
with these regimes in a way which which
both applies pressure and provides
incentives let me just say one last
thing everywhere I went in Afghanistan
everyone asked me in a you know Afghans
ask me you know are the is the u.s.
committed is the u.s. going to stay and
you know the US record in the region is
a commitment of about 15 minutes
basically you know you you you you know
you come in you do what you want to do
and then you push off basically this is
what the Afghans saw in 1991 you know
where you know after the withdrawal of
the Soviet Union this is what Pakistan
has seen several times this is what the
Central Asians gripe about in my opinion
it is absolutely vital I mean I'm not a
believer in all this clash of
civilizations and Muslim versus
Christian and you know all this huge
sort of who are that's going on in some
academic circles you know in the West
but what is very important I think to
rebuild a a trust of u.s. foreign policy
and US commitment is that the US has to
stay committed to Afghanistan over a
certain period of time I think the
message that that commitment will give
to the whole Muslim world will be that
you know for the first time the u.s. is
staying in the Muslim country it is
giving all the economic you know Avery
construction etc it's not pushing off
after 15 minutes you know and it is
actually trying to do some good in a
Muslim country and I think that message
is going to be very productive for this
you know for for the whole Muslim world
and you know I mean it's probably as
important I mean I would say as
important as the u.s. dealing with the
the crisis in the Middle East right now
and dealing with the palestinian-israeli
issue and adopting some new policy
initiatives there I think the message
that the u.s. sends the in its actions
in Afghanistan are going to be vital for
rebuilding trust and faith you know
between the Muslim peoples all over the
world and the United States in the West
thank you very much indeed
we'd like to open stage for some
questions I think there'll be four
different mics that are around the room
if you could also get up and state your
name when you ask your question we'd
really appreciate it thank you thank you
my name is Larry Ragan I'm a teacher at
von Stuben Metropolitan Science Center
earlier in your talk you mentioned about
other pockets that the United States
forces might have to get involved in if
some of these pockets are in Pakistan in
the frontier areas what are the
ramifications of the United States
actually going into Pakistan and
fighting some of the pockets of
resistance there or should the United
States stay out and should Musharraf and
the military handle that problem
thank you yeah well I mean first of all
you know the United States is already in
Pakistan the US has five bases in
Pakistan military bases in Pakistan now
you know but I think the use of ground
troops in the tribal areas between
Afghanistan and Pakistan American ground
troops will be very provocative and very
dangerous and I think much more I think
you know the Pakistan Army can possibly
do much more perhaps with us help
perhaps with you know with advisers but
I think the use of ground troops in
Pakistan in the kind of battle formation
will be extremely dangerous extremely
provocative and I think the task can be
done you know by the Pakistan Army
itself
my name is dick trodden and retired and
my question is in Central Asia what
leverage to the United States have to
come in and convince or impose their
solution on these regimes become
totalitarian and very despotic what
leverage do we have with the money that
we will contribute we'll go to the
programs that we see need to be done
thank you well you know in New York the
other day I gave a talk and the former
US ambassador to us Becca Stein was
there and he got up and said that you
know I I tried for three years to tell
us Beck's to reform and to do this and
to do that I mean you know that they're
far too stubborn and they were and they
were not interested but I think you know
the two things have happened I think you
know which has changed the kind of you
know the relationship the first is that
this is you know any sensible member of
the any Central Asian regime right now
knows that this is in a moment of
opportunity for the Central Asians after
ten years of being isolated you know
pushed to the side ignored I mean you
know suddenly these people know that you
know this is the moment for trade for
business for investment for you know
getting getting on to the kind of
international bandwagon as it were so
they are extremely keen to use this now
naturally they want to minimize the
reforms they want to carry out they want
to get onto the bandwagon but not have
to do very much so I think firstly on
that count I think the US has much
greater leverage than it had before
September the 11th the other factor is
that the people of Central Asia I think
there is enormous expectancy the
Americans have arrived you know who
nobody in Central Asia knows the
Americans I mean I mean you know let me
tell you this is the first Western
presence in Central Asia since Alexander
the Great in 3 to 7 BC you know there
has never been a Western you know an
American or European presence in this
part of the world before there is no
real perception of America it's not that
the Central Asian mass is all hated the
Americans you know or have a kind of you
know that all that you know I mean
because these
societies have been so limited I mean
you know there's no influence Hollywood
McDonald's all this kind of stuff it
doesn't exist in Central Asia so there's
really no perception yet of what the
Americans mean or stand for in Central
Asia now you can do one of two things I
mean you can do the wrong thing and and
create an anti Americanism in Central
Asia and of course the militant groups
in Central Asia would love you to do
that
because you know they would in fact I
mean what I very strongly believe and
what I'm told by some of these militants
is that you know they want to they're
organizing a campaign on the ground in
Central Asia which will be based on anti
Americanism then our local dictator is
linking up with them you know the evil
Americans and that this is going to you
know the next campaign is going to be
based on a campaign to unseat the
regimes on the basis that these race you
know on the basis of anti-americanism so
I think there's an enormous amount of
expectancy of of amongst people as to
how the Americans are going to use this
new relationship with our regime and how
it's going to push the regime to do the
right thing and that of course puts
enormous pressure on the regimes itself
because public expectations have been
raised you know so that's the new
situation since September the 11th I
think the aid going in is a new
situation what President Bush announced
in Monterrey about this new US you know
international aid commitment with
conditionalities is a new thing you know
so I think you know the situation has
changed very drastically since you know
since September the 11th you mentioned
the legacy of war in Afghanistan and I
just wondered if you would comment on
that way of life the the way of the gun
the the propaganda the dark side of man
all these kinds of things have to be
overcome and instilled a new way of
looking at living and it's so difficult
and I think that's why the United States
is so careful and being overly cautious
with the wording that it says about what
it's trying to do
over there in that nation nation
building because any kind of thing that
could be used as propaganda against the
efforts so I'm wondering how can you
deal with those people that are so anti
modern mystic thinking and thought well
you know I mean you know as I said
earlier I think you know 99% of the
population are fed up with the war
they're fed up with the deprivation and
you know and they want to be part of the
world and they want an education for
their kids and they want jobs and they
want you know economic development now I
agree with you I mean clearly you know I
mean I I'm not even so I'm not
suggesting that the US has to go in and
impose its kind of cultural or you know
social norms there I mean this is an
international effort but what I'm
suggesting is that even this
international effort is waiting for the
nod from the US you know in Europe I
mean you know European government
leaders have told me that you know if
the Americans are not going to support
an expansion of foreign peacekeepers in
other cities we can't do it we can't
send it to our Parliament's and to our
you know budget making people and to all
the rest of it if you know if the
American NGOs an American aid effort is
not going to start you know very rapidly
I mean everyone is waiting for the
Americans to take the initiative now
that doesn't mean that the Americans up
in the front what it means is that the
Americans take the initiative in this
process and then the international
community comes in after all you know
the whole world is pledged money for
rebuilding Afghanistan not just the
Americans so I think you know whatever
so what I'm suggesting is that behind
the scenes I think a great deal more has
to be done to have a more
multi-dimensional policy not necessarily
putting you in the front line of every
item whether it's education or
reconstruction and all the rest of it
given that you're in the front line in
in fighting this war I think it would be
wrong in fact for example people have
suggested well American troops should be
peacemakers I think that would be wrong
I don't think American troops who are
fighting the war in Afghanistan should
be peaceful peacekeepers there are
enough European countries Muslim
countries other countries who would be
willing to contribute peacekeepers you
know you don't have to have America
trucks being peacekeeper but the
Americans have to give the nod to this
they have to say yes to this
thank you my name is Chris Paul I'm
Canadian I'd like to ask you a question
about Hamid Karzai I was reading that
the king is not going back from Rome
this week and I know I mean Karzai is
from the from the same group as the King
so really what I'm thinking here you've
described how we've gone through the
military phase we need a phase now where
we're going to go into B into
nation-building but unless there is a
strong internal group that Karzai or
whomever is a leader can control then
you cannot do anything just by providing
money as the gentleman was saying from
the outside so could you just comment on
Hamid Karzai as an individual who might
be able to lead the country out of this
with assistance from the West thank you
well you know I've known Hamid Karzai
for 15 years he's a very competent I
mean he comes from the Pashtun from the
majority ethnic group in Afghanistan
he is the first if you like
representative or modern educated
representative of the Pashtuns which has
emerged in Afghanistan in 23 years I
mean we should remember the u.s. was
backing in the 1980s called buddy Nick
Mathia one of the most extreme leaders
are you know extremist leaders of the
Pashtuns so and then of course you know
the Taliban emerged and all the rest of
it so I think you know he has he has a
capacity he has leadership qualities now
the question the the problems are hugely
complicated he's rich
really I you know that the problem is
his writ doesn't extend in many areas of
Afghanistan the Warlord's writ extends
there but diminishing the the rich of
the Warlord's comes with all these
packages that one talks about foreign
security reconstruction money etc it
can't just come you know the political
process by kids a or by his group and or
by the king and I'm pretty certain the
king will return I mean there have been
delays I think because of some security
concerns but the the political process
cannot take place without what I said
you know the partnership of the
international
to the other arm and I think you know if
the other arm is there backing him to
the hilt I'm I'm optimistic I think it
can work I think the bottom line in
Kabul right now let me tell you is that
despite the kind of messiness of the
situation no warlord can defy Hamid
kills a no warlord can denounce him no
matter how much the wallowed may hate
him and may dislike the central
government no warlord can publicly
denounce him
no warlord has the capacity now to
attack Kabul or to try and militarily
undermine the present central government
now you know that's a huge change in
Afghanistan now it may not be very much
bye-bye you know normal standards but
you know somebody who's been living with
this warlordism for 23 years I mean I
tell you that's a huge change the
Warlord's are diminished you know yes
they have to be diminished much more and
quick more quickly and and and at a
faster pace and all the rest of it and
they may be kind of flourishes that
they'll make and they may you know carry
as some of them have been carrying out
ethnic killings in in in northern
Afghanistan in the last few weeks but
you know if they are much more
diminished than they were three months
ago or even one month ago you know I
mean I gave you this example of the
education thing I mean you know this is
chipping away at this kind of edifice
but it's not going to happen you know
they're not going to be able to do it on
their own I mean kids there's not going
to be able to do it on his own
somebody else quick question you
mentioned that it's essential that the
u.s. take an active role in the
political process of Afghanistan might
you speak to what might happen if indeed
they didn't and from what I'm
understanding is that the Northern
Alliance specifically the pan Jerry's
members of ministry and the government
have a significant power position and
could or may use that in influencing the
future Loya Jirga in June
it's just wondering if you might be able
to elaborate a little bit on that and
give us your insight thank you well you
know I agree with you I think the
biggest the biggest domestic problem
internal problem in Afghanistan right
now actually is not the Warlord's the
biggest internal problem is the role
being played by the punch series these
are the leaders of the Tariq faction of
the Northern Alliance who helped you
know the u.s. win the war in Afghanistan
and they were the main army on the
ground you know the troops on the ground
who who who took all these cities etc
while the u.s. were kind of doing the
bombing they have now occupied three
ministries the most important ministries
in Afghanistan in the cabinet there are
in fact stuffing the counter the
ministries with their own people and
they're trying to monopolize by it so it
is a very dangerous situation Hamid kill
today is not called their bluff yet and
I think you know one of the reasons he
is not called his bluff is because the
Americans have not called his their
bluff yet and you know the I think the
United Nations the Americans the Western
alliance needs to call their bluff and
needs to roll back a bit from the kind
of alliance that they've had with the
north you know with the stark faction
with the punch series now again that's
what I mean when I say that if the US
military I mean the military that you
know the US military's had this
relationship for the last six months
with the Northern Alliance now now you
need you know a process of political
process etcetera
you need a more nuanced policy you need
to step back from these guys and you
need to thump them very hard and tell
them to bathe you know and if if the
Americans could tell them to behave
followed by the Brits and followed by
the UN then Hamid because they can also
tell them to pay but Hamid kids day has
no army of his own he can't tell them to
behave right away you know he has he
doesn't have support in the tragic
population you know the way that the
punch series do so again you know it's a
very complicated situation I mean that
again you have I go back to this thing
this is a partnership you have to work
together the international community
needs to work with the central
government to resolve some of these
problems
I hope the the international community
will wake up to this danger and
particularly out the Americans will wake
up to this danger before the law Jerrica
takes place it will be messy what can I
say to be messy you know it'll be messy
my name is khaki boat in your comments
about the need for nation building I
couldn't agree with you more
but where do we stand in the debate
going on within the Bush administration
between the Hawks who want to go after
al Qaeda and now Iraq versus the need
for nation-building that lets say by the
Colin Powell faction could you comment
on that well I think you know you know
very firmly first of all anything that
for me detracts from this region
Afghanistan Central Asia Pakistan right
now is a you know is a waste of time
right now
you know I think the US needs to
concentrate on this region and of course
to you know pursue al Qaeda in other
countries wherever they may exist I
think any kind of action in Iraq is
going to lead to a lessening of
commitment to stabilizing Afghanistan
and
peripheral region I think the axis of
evil concept unfortunately has detracted
very seriously from the US war against
terrorism because the axis of evil is
seen in the Muslim world and and in
Europe even as a reflection of US
foreign policy not as the as a
reflection of the international
coalition against terrorism you know the
US wants to get rid of Saddam Hussein
and the u.s. wants to get rid of the
Iranians or the North Koreans or
whatever this is not the demand you know
this is not part of the u of the engine
of the war against terrorism this is not
part of the international coalition this
is a particular need of us or a desire
of US foreign policy or a desire of this
particular administration and I think
you know I think you know the Bush
administration has blundered in this
because it has created now a kind of
wall or a barrier between particularly
the Europeans and the end and the
Americans secondly I mean very simply I
mean I think you know common sense would
dictate given the absolute crisis in the
Middle East right now between Palestine
and Israel I think any kind of
escalation or provocation outside this
the idea the israeli-palestinian
conflict it would be catastrophic for us
long-term interests you know in the
Middle East and in the Muslim world and
and you know intervening against Iraq
right now with without trying to help
resolve some of the or reduce the
tensions between Israel and the
Palestinians would be enormous ly risky
and dangerous
my name is ray cliff every time I hear
someone from the Middle East talk my
understanding I have two understandings
number one we could solve their problem
with our military and certainly we could
solve it with copious quantities of
money and I guess it would be refreshing
to me to hear from you folks say this is
what you can do America now this is what
we're doing but I never hear what you're
doing for example you said you know the
military's been over there and you guys
have caught one terrorist and my
question is why haven't you caught any
you live there you know the language
where was Islam for example when all
these lunatic fundamentalist clerics
were raising their armies and exporting
terrorism around the world and is there
ever a chance that the Middle East is
going to separate church and state
because if they don't America might as
well stay armed well you know I mean if
you read the Taliban book I mean the the
point I'd be making all along about the
rise of extremism in the Muslim world is
that this is not the the West's fault
this is the Muslim world's fault you
know and we do need a Reformation I mean
we do need major changes I mean the real
problems go back to Muslim regimes who
have not tackled these these issues they
have not democratized after the end of
the Cold War they did not carry out
economic reform after the end of the
Cold War you know they didn't join those
sort of the whole you know the way the
world was moving you know for the last
ten years so certainly I mean you know I
think for the first time now opposed
September the 11 thank God there is a
very serious debate going on in
countries like Pakistan in the media in
the press I mean the Pakistanis are for
the first time publicly asking
politicians leaders of civil society
what the hell will be doing supporting
the Taliban for six years why did we
allow the army to do this you know
people are asking these questions for
the first time I think in the last six
weeks or so a debate has has even arisen
in the tightly control press in Saudi
Arabia there have been adverse comments
for the first time if you remember this
incident about the schoolgirls who were
locked in there you know in the
you know who burned to death
unfortunately you know so I think
Muslims who are both Muslim and
patriotic and nationalistic are very
keen that our regimes deal with these
problems you know but I think at the
same time measures need to be taken by
the United States I mean you know I
think the last ten years also you know
the US has not really been involved into
the rest of the world there has been
such a dumbing down if you like of us
information to the US public about
foreign policy about what's been going
on in the rest of the world you know
this is this is the fault of the media
this is the fault of you know all sorts
of other things but the fact is you know
I'd be the most common question I got
about September the 11th was well why do
you know why the Muslims hate us so much
so I mean my gut reaction is well
haven't you been following what's been
going on in the world you know not what
the US has been doing but what is being
what you know the lack of what the
Muslim regimes themselves have been
doing for the last 10 years since the
end of the Cold War so what I'm saying
to you is that I am you know I hope with
some regimes you know this is our
responsibility essentially the the issue
of fundamentalism and terrorism and all
the rest of it I mean the Middle East is
altogether you know a different issue I
mean that is it's an international issue
I mean the support that you know Israel
gets for example from the United States
is completely you know unbalanced if you
like from what you know the Palestinians
may be getting from the United States
but as far as this extremism concerned I
think you know I hold myself responsible
first of all I don't hold you
responsible you know and I hope my
regimes and if I'm standing here and
criticizing my own regime which is a
military dictatorship I hope that you
know people will understand that people
you know people like us there are many
many parks alleys Muslims all over the
world who want change and reform and I
hope we get the leaders who want change
in reform also unfortunately we haven't
had those kinds of leaders
my name is Mohammed I'm from India I
have a question I have heard a whole lot
about all these issues the militants the
terrorists and all these but I have
hardly ever heard anything about the
root causes of the emergence of all
these militant groups all these
terrorists unless and until we address
this issue how are we going to solve the
problem I would like to have a comment
thank you
I mean root causes I mean if you I mean
you know I think everyone is to blame I
mean you know i-i've just said that I
think you know I mean we I mean you know
Muslim regimes are to blame for the lack
of democratization and reform and you
know state building an institutional
building that they have been involved in
the Americans are also to blame you know
the Americans in the 1980s backed the
most extreme elements in Afghanistan for
the first two years in in in of the
Taliban rise the Americans allowed
Pakistan supported Pakistan and Saudi
Arabia to fund an armed the Taliban you
know now there was a change of American
policy after 1996 and the capture of
Kabul a change that was by the way led
not by the Clinton administration but
was led by American feminists you know
who were demanding from the Clinton
administration as to what the hell you
know Clinton was doing backing these
people who are locking up you know I've
gone women so you know I mean I'm not
into the blame game I don't I know I
think we should get kind of above and
beyond the blame game I you know what I
would like to see is people come up with
with solutions I would like to see the
Americans come up with solutions the
West come up with solutions and you know
Muslim and Muslim regimes come up with
solutions you know one thing I you know
I I really do want to say I mean I
really don't bind to at all this kind of
Islam versus Christianity clash of
civilizations the struggles going on
right now I mean the rise of terrorism
these are political struggles you know
Osama bin Laden wanted to topple the
Saudi regime
and regimes in the Gulf and if that
meant taking on the United States he was
prepared to do that
you know the Taliban wanted to lock up
you know you know we're willing to
spread the ideology around Pakistan in
another areas they wanted political
power this is a game of political power
you're going to counter this in a
political and even then a military way
you know but this is not about Islam and
religion and Christianity as much yes I
mean Islam is used by Osama bin Laden as
the kind of bandwagon to try and promote
his cause but I think you know most
Muslims know that you know what he was
promoting has nothing to do with Islam
this was a struggle for power a struggle
for toppling his own regime at home
ahmed rashid has reported on Afghanistan
for over 20 years he's the author of the
resurgence of Central Asia Taliban and
his latest jihad the rise of militant
Islam in Central Asia as published by
Yale University Press
visit yale.edu /y u P to get more